[Music]  in America everyone hangs out at coffee  shops and Russia they go to Rubin snap  or vodka rooms  the name comes from the word doom cut or  shot glass so chances are you've got a  pretty good idea of what goes on here  now I left Russia when I was 15 so I  didn't get to experience this part of  Russian culture but I've enlisted a  couple of experts to help me make up for  lost time this what you put a privately  what's up with this room commode cap  another room each net but you don't sit  there for hours  you stop by have a drink and go on about  your business dancing as your journey  for the night you learn the vodka rooms  aren't about drinking vodka at all  premium vodka the terrible oceans  preservation is called mutiny opposite  it's almost apakah you whip you situated  to be snatched gift of shares it's all  about who you are breaking away  [Music]  [Music]